um any any songs that uh we don't know
about that you're sitting on that you
you can kind of like you know like
without i mean look there you got a
drake feature so it doesn't get it
doesn't get bigger than that unless
unless you tell me you got the whole
feature you know what i mean which i'm
not even sure is bigger than the drake
feature to be
a hundred percent honest shout out to
jay-z but they're right there you know
what i mean
but
oh you got the ozuna joint the [ __ ]
i see you about to be in puerto rico
bros can you go ken he said the paisa
dance
i think pisces mexico right that's
mexicans i don't know what i'm doing
can you like are you allow are you are
you still on um
papers are you like can you move but i
think i'll go out there
i'm saying like you're allowed to move
around like freely
yeah you got to go to puerto rico to
shoot the video
he's a shout out to ozuna i know he's um
he's opening the cookies in puerto rico
with with burner
[Music]
yes